au milieu d'un quartier en ruines où
certains immeubles sont encore en
flammes cet habitant de marioupol film
sa famille et ses quelques valises après
des semaines de combats il espère enfin
quitter la ville
voici mes enfants sur la masia n'ya
héros dc cas on est réveillé depuis 5
heures ce matin on a fait nos valises et
on espère partir ce qu'on a vécu je ne
le souhaite à personne les convois que
ces milliers de civiles espèrent depuis
plusieurs jours les voici des dizaines
d'autobus jaunes destinés à l'évacuation
des habitants de marioupol
des bus qui ont quitté la ville de
zappos ridja puis pris la route de
bergues yank avant d'arriver à marioupol
dont l'évacuation pourrait débuter
demain
nous avons reçu dans la nuit un message
de la croix rouge sur lequel la
fédération de russie confirme qu'elle
est prête à ouvrir l'accès du convoi
humanitaire de la ville de mario polèse
12h45 du sont partis ce matin
à tobrouk selon les associations plus de
cent mille civils seraient encore
coincés à marioupol ville bombardée par
l'aviation russe le maire de la commune
demande à la communauté internationale
d'agir au plus vite kitsch schizo coup
nos ressources en eau et en nourriture
s'épuisent nous appelons la communauté
internationale à réagir et à s'unir pour
la seule et unique but sauver notre
population
ce matin avant le cessez le feu
plusieurs détonations ont encore été
entendues à mario paul la croix rouge se
dit prêt à débuter l'évacuation des
derniers civils dès demain si les
conditions de sécurité sont respectées